robert spencer as russia continues to
destroy the people and the
infrastructure of ukraine the world
makes a lot of speeches they're passing
sanctions and the killing just goes on
and on and on robert what's it going to
take to stop putin
i wish i knew barry if i knew i guess
i'd be a rich man now or at least a
powerful one but in any case
uh what i'm mainly concerned about is
that this is going to escalate into
world war 3 because even though we were
promised that the adults were going to
be back in charge in washington it
certainly looks like the children's hour
they just keep on escalating the
situation instead of calming it down and
at the same time our military has been
so concerned with enforcing the woke
agenda
that uh i'm deeply concerned that if we
do get into this we might not get out
very well